all right well we see that both of these
players have four points in top of the
screen that means they have one win and
uh one draw so far today new scoring
system this season in the melt water
champions chess tour in the ratio three
to one seven hundred and fifty dollars
for a win two hundred and fifty dollars
for a draw
so it is a lot more lucrative now to win
those games and here we go with the
king's form yeah and ivanka has called
the opening correctly
both sides opening with their king's
pawn when magnus lost to essepenko in
vaikansei a couple of years ago it was
in the sicilian defense where it was
really really sharp that battle but
esopenko navigated the complications
better than his opponent so now it's the
italian game something we've seen a lot
on the first season of the champions
chess tour but also we saw in the world
championship match with magnus and now
magnus just developing his bishop one
square very safe very solid it looks
like all the pieces will be on the board
for a long time and this one will become
a maneuvering battle
meanwhile white castling the king
black doing the same yep
so far so good and now this opening is
really complicated because there's a
variety of
peace development uh moves that white
can play and there's lots and lots of
choice but um espanko decides to play a
relatively solid line which is just to
develop his knight and now he does what
magnus carlsen likes to do himself which
is expand as much as possible on the
queen side by advancing the pawn
how is magnus going to react to his
favorite strategy well
we'll see what do you think you'll play
for training of bishops
possibly so black can bring his light
squared bishop out now i was going to
say it's just magnus's style to do the
same to copy he doesn't like to allow
his opponents to gain space especially
with their rook spawns their corner
pawns so magnus there blocking the
invite advice advance sorry of whites a
porn uh white alice porn there and
it will slow down the pace of the game
for a while the italian game does have
that type of characteristic where later
on in the late middle game maybe early
end game that's when things really start
to happen i don't think we'll see any
attacks on either sides king anytime
soon but it's all about who can put
their piece on better squares who can
make the correct types of trades and uh
magnus he's vastly experienced in these
types of positions
and uh yeah i'm expecting sepenko now
maybe just to move the white rook next
to the kings to the center maybe why
could just push a pawn to secure some
squares on his king side
um as well plenty of options but uh yeah
no opening theory here this one isn't
about memory work or about homework
it's just about understanding of the
position
yeah i i agree with you there 100
because whenever i tried to play this
opening with the white pieces i was lost
in the whole move orders and then it
kind of dawned on me actually something
you said it's all kind of hinges on
whose bishop is better
and that and that's it and okay
you are getting the prediction
spot on david the rook has moved and now
yeah and now i'm kind of curious will um
magnus just offer trade of bishops or
will he just kind of
do something else you know maybe push a
king's pawn one square forward and not
the king's pawn the rook pawn next to
the king
push it one square forward just because
it's a move
nice controlling the circuit of the
white knight yeah i think that one maybe
is the most likely from magnus so just
pushing black's h pawn one square um
that's quite a thematic move in this
type of position just covering any
potential advances by white's pieces
also it does allow black to maybe
maneuver a bit later on
it's not magnus's style necessarily to
trade off the light squared bishops here
with black because that would give him
potentially a pawn structure that he
likes to play against
rather than have himself
so i would be slightly surprised to see
magnus offer to trade those light squad
bishops even though that's maybe one of
the most logical moves in the position
um either way magnus he'll do something
useful he'll slowly improve a piece
slowly improve his pawn structure and
he'll hope that uh he's solid enough to
withstand a potential advance by
esopenko in the center at some point i i
just got excited because i was checking
the database and i was like okay there's
a whole range of moves but black does
have a very aggressive plan at his
disposal which is actually to tuck his
king into the corner
step back with the knight to where the
king already originally is and then go
forward
yeah
how likely do you think this is going to
be
um i think unlikely unless your name is
levon aronian this is iranian's favorite
plan in the position to tuck the king
away as your mankind mentioned and if
white say plays a normal move just
pushes a pawn covering the square to
stop the black bishop or knight using it
then suddenly the knight retreats and as
evanka mentioned it's all to do with
pushing the f pawn forward f forward and
uh trying to undermine white center from
the side so for example again if white
just moves the bishop this pawn pushes
forward and either now as white you
trade off but now black has kind of a
rock-solid pawn formation in the center
and white has one pawn fewer in the
middle or you allow the continued
advance
for example if you just move uh you
allow the continued advance of black's
pawns and suddenly this black pawn chain
is connect four already but uh it will
also be joined by further pawn pushes
and black would go on the attack on this
side of the board magnus doesn't go for
this however um this uh this idea is
mostly linked to levon aronian nobody
else is really brave enough to do this
open up their own king magnus instead
bring his knight forward and kaya i
heard a sound because the evaluation bar
doesn't like it yes
there well it definitely had a reaction
and you know when it's above one then
it's usually something to
at least notice i guess definitely uh
fully agree and actually i think this is
quite a clever move as well by esopenko
the white knight might have looked nice
and pretty on the square it sat on but
it's retreated it's going over towards
the white king side it's actually going
to park itself next to its other white
knight but now as well the white sea
pawn has been freed up it will push
forward to the square previously
occupied by that knight and kick away
black's knight from this uh half of the
board so
logical move it will involve magnus
having to lose a bit more time later on
and this is just a typical
maneuver that you see time and time
again in the italian opening in the
spanish opening it's all about pattern
recognition and essepenko using those
patterns he's
kind of assimilated in his brain just
goes for it immediately barely spending
any time
i quite like it for white i quite like
it for white as well and i have to say
there's only one game in my database i
was quite curious who the players were
the player of the white pieces was
jordan van forest
who was uh magnus carlsen second during
the world championship match against
janna pontiac
and uh black was ivan evis ivan nisovich
from serbia and there that game finished
with white winning okay so
we saw that actually in the previous
round um white had a good score in an
opening magnus chose and magnus went on
to win and now white has at least one
kind of prolific victory in this
position and essepenko with the white
pieces
yeah i i just have a feeling magnus
would rather have this position with
white than with black
and uh it's magnus over the last season
of the tour
we saw him use the italian time and time
again
nearly winning nearly every single game
with white in the italian he seems to
love these types of positions with white
but that doesn't necessarily translate
into loving the positions from the other
side of the board um often i find if i
play an opening with white if i play it
as well with black i'm slightly biased i
just prefer white's position i prefer
white's ideas i'm more familiar with
them
and uh okay magnus finally does offer
the trade of bishops
um not normally his style as we
mentioned but maybe he just felt there
was nothing else to do white's light
squared bishop was superior to that
black bishop
of the evaluation bar off over to white
side again
something else i'm noticing is that
andre is very you know loose and fidgety
and i don't know if he's nervous or
excited or is he like this in
over-the-board chess as well or is this
something he's bringing into online
chess here yeah he's a bit like this
over the board i noticed i played him in
the grand swiss um back in october
november in latvia and i managed to win
eventually but i noticed when he was
doing well he was quite fidgety when he
was doing badly it was clearly visible
in his face he just didn't stay at the
board wow he's walking around like kind
of exhaling and
um
yeah so he's quite
i don't think with his face necessarily
but just with his body language he's
quite emotive
i also can confirm because i also played
him uh one year in the grand swiss in
2019 and we had a tense position and he
was
he was losing focus but as soon as i
played a move that he didn't like i
thought was bad for me he immediately
sat up and he was like and then like you
say fidgety and he kind of gave the game
away that yeah i made the mistake and
that was it he was going to pounce yeah
so conclusion is if he's doing well
he'll be fidgety if he's not doing well
he'll be shaking his head probably and
um
it'll be quite clear oh
okay
he's teasing us now he's doing a bit of
everything
i do love this about online chess the
players are definitely giving us some
body language and andre is one of those
we did have a couple of moves on the
board what's happening yeah a couple of
moves so very logical from both sides
the light squared bishops did get traded
and now there is a small imbalance in
the position it's all to do with black's
central pawn structure
those doubled e pawns
they can be a strength black does have a
semi open line for his rook now but they
can be a weakness especially long term
in the end game so magnus actually has a
fantastic track record in this type of
position
against that pawn structure how will he
fare with that pawn structure himself
just to demonstrate some ideas and uh
maybe you can talk us through this
ivanka um these pawns
what do you think they can be targeted
right they can come out at some point
exactly and one of the key features
about that pawn structure is that
yes
the f line is open for the black rook
but these double pawns they just can't
move and often you judge that whether
double pawns are good by whether they're
able to move forward and these two there
are absolutely stuck there's no way that
the deporn
the queen's born is actually going to
assist in the movement nothing can
happen so that's that situation is very
very static and that means that they can
be targets and david highlighted a move
the queen can come out and attack the
horn in fact she can attack two pawns
if she's feeling very spicy i'm not sure
immediately because the black knight
will jump out attacking the queen and
defending these two pawns as we
mentioned but um white could easily
prepare that white could just plant the
bishop in the center guarding this
square and then now the
white queen will jump out and i think
it's quite unpleasant you also mentioned
this pawn push with black sometimes it's
playable but
even if white just ignores this this
pawn structure is so fragile now
two of the pawns are frozen they're
completely locked down but this one as
well it doesn't really want to push
forward you lose all flexibility and you
definitely don't want to ever trade in
the center because now look at them
they're isolated they're even weaker
than before so even if you get a chance
to push forward normally in chess we
recommend occupying occupying the center
with your pawns but actually they're
just as weak here and vulnerable as they
were previously so okay meanwhile most
logical move in the position played by
essepenko this piece doing nothing he
brings it out using all of his pieces
and this is also a rock-solid formation
um yeah so black can never really use
this semi-open f-file for his advantage
because white's minor pieces are just
poised perfectly
but then the question is what is black's
plan for moving forward i mean
he can't move his you know that bishop
move was really good by esopenko because
suddenly the black knight can't develop
to its natural square
and uh the queen
is in the way of the black rooks
connecting with each other and she
doesn't actually have a great square to
go to either
maybe she can mostly i was exactly yeah
often she tries this maneuver but
actually she's just going to be staring
off against some very strong
well-fortified white knights so
it feels a bit slow also the queen move
would allow white to jump out with a
double attack
as we mentioned and this would be very
awkward for black to face do you really
have to contort yourself and retreat
this knight to defend your pawns look at
this this is just passive
it's a bit sad and now white is the one
able to break in the center when ready
maybe white will just bring all the
pieces to the party first and then start
mobilizing it's awkward for magnus
carson i don't think he'll like his
position let's go back to the players
because uh right now white does have a
small stable advantage i feel we should
have a rhyme for double pawns you know
we have it for so many of the situations
on the board and we talk about double
poles all the time but we don't have a
rhyme for the double pawns doing oh
that's true no we don't we don't have
anything double pawns are
what rhymes with
i'm going to throw it out to the people
out in the world using the hashtag chess
champs yeah that should be the rhyme for
the double pawns
we need to get the hive minds together
because i remember when we were stuck
with night in the corner
twitter came to our rescue and they gave
us a rhyme yep i can't remember said
rhyme but
it was certainly good ones so yeah
twitter of us
please help us
come up with a rhyme for double pawns
yeah i think that's the one thing we
learned from the first season of the
mount water champions festival that our
twitter followers uh our viewers they're
far more creative than us
and wow yeah the
creativity out in the world
with our followers is amazing i'm gonna
be eager to see now if we get some cool
suggestions it's very hard to find
something that rhymes with porn
dawn
dawn horn
mourn mourn
i will mourn that double pawn ah
there we go i don't know
that's a very good one
well look see now when you play a game
david and ah you want to make that move
but oh i will mourn that double pawn i
will not make that move i might not be
able to play against magnus h-10 but i
can come up with rhymes
yeah okay so we actually have a move
from magnus and actually a little plan
he's actually activated his knight
really
because you've anchored the knight came
from that square on the last move yeah
that's true he literally just retreated
his knight
white made a very useful move and then
he brought it back where it came from
magnus has just lost two moves
i mean the knight maybe is better here
than where it previously stood but i
don't understand it and esopenko there
kind of shook his head being like what
are you up to magnus what's the plan
um and personally i don't get it at the
very least white could play a kind of
practical joke and retreat the white
bishop back where it came from and said
okay we've had this position before
that's the second time what do you want
to do now
just players are not that kind of chess
players aren't that great if they say
you lost some moves
i will take advantage of that
yeah but i like the joke though if it
was a non-important game i would just
retreat my bishop and say okay magnus
you lost some time yeah what are you
doing next but
no strange one um just to explain as
well on the board what's just happened
because
how do we explain this in this position
it's black to play this is two moves ago
we're rewinding black simply retreated
his knight back quite a logical move
opening up his rook and as we mentioned
maybe the knight wants to jump over to
this side of the board white now brought
the bishop out also a very useful move
developing a piece improving a piece and
now magnus just brought the back uh
brought the knight back i can barely
even explain it
with words here because it just looks
like he's lost time and
he could have spent that time more
usefully bringing his queen forward
connecting the black rooks he could have
spent that time maybe just shuffling his
king in the corner to a safer square he
could have done plenty of more useful
things but now magnus i don't know what
his plan is
i guess he wants to meet the queen
jumping out to attack this pawn attack
this diagonal with moving his own queen
forward setting a nasty trap queen takes
pawn now would actually trap the white
queen this white queen would be doomed
and punished for her greed but
i mean
is that really worth spending two moves
for just a simple trap like that one
and if white does bring the queen out
for example if black does reply with
this queen move
uh estepenko now could just maybe push a
pawn forward bring his rook to the
center there's many useful moves uh with
which he can profit from black's loss of
time loss of tempe so yeah very very
strange stuff happening on the board it
shows that magnus can't be too
comfortable with his position no he's
he's struggling for a plan and maybe
he's just resorting to those
psychological
employees you know you kind of say okay
i'm going to be very provocative here
and i'm going to invite you to punish me
for wasting time
on the other hand i do admire magnus for
admitting that his last move was a
mistake
and did remind me of the norwegian
mountain rules
the mountain routes yeah the mountain
rules i
have to say something about norwegian
pub quizzes i'm really traumatizing
is there like a mensa test
and one of the questions was what other
how many mountain rules are there in
norway and i was like i have 27 i just
said like that the answer is nine but
anyway one of the rules is never too
late to turn yep yep that's the most
important one is it is it number one
okay well
so here it is in the in the position you
know you should never be too proud to
make to admit that you've made a mistake
and uh retreat your night to where it
came from yeah i've recently been
watching on chess of all the seven
deadly chess sins by jonathan rousen one
based on one of my favorite books and
that's based on the seven deadly sins
and one of the seven deadly sins is
pride you can't be too proud you can't
think okay i've chosen this plan it's
got to be a good one i'm going to
persevere with it because sometimes it
turns out to be a bad plan you just got
to rewind i'm just going to say okay i
lost two moves and life goes on so um
the seven deadly chest and says we see
there there's a special offer on but um
it does talk through some of the reasons
why we make mistakes as humans some of
the psychology and
actually magnus yes he maybe made some
mistakes on the board but in terms of
psychology it shows how strong he is and
how flexible he is even if he makes a
mistake he he's fine with it he'll just
go back and start again and now we've
seen some trades in the center i'm not
actually a fan of this from essepenko
the evaluation bar still thinks white's
doing well but he has clarified the
situation in the center magnus was
struggling for a plan but now he's made
it simpler he's made it more clear for
magnus as to what he should be doing so
also black's double pawns in the center
one of them's been traded off so black's
pawn stretching now very very healthy
again
and uh esopenko leaning forward ivanka
you said that meant that he likes his
position right yeah moving forward and
he must like it because he's actually
going on the attack he's trying to use
the fact he's got two extra moves
compared to earlier by
jumping with his knight
attacking a vulnerable pawn the black
pawn on e6 was up for grabs it was
attacked
and black's had to defend it and now the
attack continues
sepenko continuing to gain space
i
still not 100 sure that i'm keen on what
he's done yes he's gained time even more
black's knight is forced back to its
back rank breaking the connection
between blacks rooks but the stakes are
higher long term now black is actually
doing fine if the queen's come off if
some pieces get elim uh get traded get
eliminated
and now he's maneuvering his knight the
whole way back this is creative from the
young russian
putting his knight on the edge of the
board knights in the rim are dim but
he's going to reroute it back towards
the center and more importantly the
white queen her diagonal has opened up
she's going to jump forward maybe onto
the same line as the black king and try
to start attacking yeah dangerous stuff
actually yeah the more i look at it the
more it is logical but
it wasn't my first instinct at least no
definitely not my first instinct and now
i look at it even more i'm just like oh
i like it the knight will jump to
the f4 square and then the queen will
join in and they'll be like oh a pincer
attack on this weak pawn that black has
there's a lot of danger and remember
three is the magical number when it
comes to mating attacks and once the
queen gets involved
yeah it's uh it's
troubling stuff for the world champion
yeah actually yeah you're completely
right the more i look at it the more i
think actually white is still in charge
black is still struggling to find
concrete ideas white's moves are
automatic simply next maybe black can
try jumping forward with the knight
making this one less attractive because
now the knight can create a fork a
double attack against the white rooks
but
i don't know it feels like black is
playing on the wrong side of the board
here and even if white were to lose
material which he doesn't want to do but
even if you were then white's idea of
jumping forward with the knight
attacking this pawn they would still
exist and this black king very
uncomfortable with this tension so i'm
pretty sure magnus will try a move such
as this one this is an outpost after all
but he knows he's going to face a
blistering attack at some point in the
near future especially with this white
queen jumping forward wow two games in a
row struggling magnus carlsen against
two of the youngest players in the
tournament
yeah on paper it looked like he had a
relatively straightforward day you know
he has three whites out of four you know
facing abdusatorov and uh essie pengu
who aren't the highest rated but they're
young
they are dangerous
and uh you know we asked for assistance
about rhyming yeah double pawns as well
twitter you have been awesome
and uh i have to share with you will
hargreaves uh idea which is like double
pawns are troubled
nice ones so much better than mine and
scent helen's chess club also has a
variation which is pawns that are
doubled they're going to be troublesome
nice ones i love it yes
so that's you know and this is so nice
for me at my beginner level
for when i play chess to have these
rhymes in my head they're so helpful
actually yeah with you know knights on
the rim and now the the troubled pawns
the double pawns
it's gonna be in the it's gonna be in
the front of my head yeah please write a
book you know all these chess sayings
all these idioms maybe we should maybe
we should coin like make a note of all
our sayings yeah one of my favorite
moments during the tour finals was
actually before the tour finals uh david
myself played a game of partner chess
against anish giri and asia lynn
martinez from chest 24 and basically we
played with all using all of our
expressions i love it even anish gary
was quoting back some of our things
he couldn't deal with the moves we were
crushing
you won
yeah i think we did english power drew
one and one yeah i think so yeah
so of course you did yeah the sayings
they do work and it i mean they don't
necessarily need to dictate everything
you do but they're just triggers in some
positions you're struggling to find a
maneuver you just ask yourself where you
know what pawn structure do i want where
do i want to put this piece and these
sayings they come in handy yeah i do it
as well through my own game yeah i have
to say it's often at those moments you
know when you sometimes when you're
playing chess you lose yourself in the
calculations all those variations and
everything and when you're right in the
thick of it sometimes you lose sight of
what the actual objective is and often
when you take that step back and look at
the position from a distance you can
kind of remember how the phrases go the
saying goes and they can kind of just
form the outline oh yeah towards
for these uh variations
guide you back into the right plan
because it's so easy just to kind of
lose yourself
overthink another deadly sin
yeah every time you say lose yourself i
keep thinking of that
yeah me too and uh one player who's lost
himself maybe in his own mind right now
is magnus carlsen he's spent four and a
half minutes on this move and he's under
three minutes already he's not even
moved 20.
in a classical game he would normally
have an hour an hour and a half on his
clock by now but
he clearly doesn't like his position
he's spent a lot of his time now on this
one move that means he's struggling to
come up with a plan
struggling to come up with where to put
the pieces and it's understandable
despite the fact the computer maybe
thinks white has less of an advantage
now that doesn't necessarily
show anything about the ease of play and
white's plan is simple it's
straightforward as we showed the white
queen is coming out the white knight is
going to recentralize what's black's
plan
and uh i've been sitting here thinking
about it i can't find one either or one
that looks good
sooner or later though magnus will just
have to move yeah two minutes on his
clock and he's playing a youngster who
is super sharp super quick and he's
going to attack him with everything he's
got and has beaten him before yeah
you know
psychologically that's important magnus
himself said right he he's only keen
really to defend the world title against
someone younger from the next generation
because that would be more of a
challenge he thinks he can beat anyone
similar age to him
he's played napoliyachi he's played
karjakin carawana who all within a
couple of years but and this next
generation did you predict this move
immediately i thought it might come next
i thought black's knight might jump
forward and then the rook would uh lift
but magnus likes his rook lifts that's
one thing i've learned
over the years
i just played it immediately so
indirectly maybe that rook later on the
sixth rank will guard the weak e6 pawn
that you mentioned and then the black
knight can come forward or maybe even
retreat itself if necessary
all right nice defensive technique
wasn't it uh what it was uh andreas
panko right that magnus lost against in
tata steel last year whereas kind of his
bad you know form kind of started a
little bit for magnus girls and he had a
few quite bad tournaments after or
at least some bad games and some bad
results after that yeah it wasn't just
the fact he lost to esopenos the fact
that he was completely outplayed from
move one to the end of the game and
sometimes magnus does lose but we're
used to seeing him lose from positions
of strength where he maybe tries too
hard or takes too many risks but this
game from move one till move 35 or
whenever it was um yeah esopenko just
smoothly outplayed him wow and magnus
didn't really have a chance so yeah
essepenko is capable of that on his day
um still
these younger players they're maybe not
as consistent as someone like magnus is
the older generation but
they are very dangerous and esopenko
leaning forward meaning he likes his
position yeah yes
and i have to say one thing referring
back to that game from tata still was
that i noticed that magnus also lost
time in the opening
yeah he wasted a lot of time and here
you have the same features you know he
moved his knight to one square and then
he moved it back again and uh esopenko
well he's a man with a plan
he's activated his queen
and uh wow
that one
he did just ignore the whole idea and
he's kind of looks like he's signaling
that he's going to attack
the pawn on the queen side which looks a
little bit irrelevant to me if you're
yeah i mean this looks like the type of
move that magnus age 10 on the app would
play against me and i would panic but
you don't expect to see this from
magnus age 31
he's completely ignoring white's plans
on the king side which is actually the
most important half of the board right
now that's where the attack is brewing
against the black king and he's just
going pawn hunting with that black rook
he can't do that yet because white's
knight and white's queen now are teamed
up against the black e6 pawn
he's going to have to move his knight to
defend that pawn i think the black
knight on the sixth rank has to move out
the way so black's rook can connect and
defend some vulnerable pawns but
it's not looking like there's a great
square for the black knight either you
move over again to that left side where
you're not really contributing or you
retreat
and
nobody likes to retreat especially the
top players we've mentioned magnus
doesn't commit the sin of pride too
often
but
retreating another piece to the back
rank
that would be a hard pill to swallow it
feels so passive doesn't it it feels
like you're curling up into a little
wall which incidentally we have seen
magnus do yeah i can remember in the
world championship when he played
against the pomegranate you know he
needed to
put his all his pieces in a little
compact square and he managed to defend
um
set up a fortress and wow what is this
okay this is either very good or it's
very very bad uh magnus he's gone pawn
hunting as i mentioned this is the type
of thing that maybe we're used to seeing
from younger players where they're just
focused on their own plans again seven
deadly since this is egoism focusing on
your own plans neglecting the opponent's
ideas but
that pawn wasn't really doing much
anyway and now white can win a very
important pawn in the center
why can't white just take that pawn
ivanka i'm i'm asking the same question
i want to take it with my my night
my night white night
and then
and then i want to be a little bit spicy
and i kind of want to introduce my other
knight into the f5 square
just kind of saying hey
nine or five we'll thrive yeah another
rhyme that we've coined on the tour and
this looks deadly going for the black
king but i do notice maybe there's a
tactical trick here after white tonight
takes this pawn there is a pin on this
diagonal and white currently isn't
threatening anything so maybe black can
retreat the knight and actually win a
piece here because this white knight no
matter where it moves will
lead to the loss of white's queen and
importantly for black as well um this is
quite hard visually to see it took me a
while as well
black's knight on this square looks
terrible but it is guarding the
important pawn in front of black's king
so there's no way to break through and
checkmate yet black's pieces they look
so ugly parked here on the back rank but
they do keep everything under guard and
that is why i think isopenko decided
okay he can't take with a knight because
of that nasty pin this knight retreat a
very difficult move to see but he
spotted it and he decided instead to
take this pawn with his queen we see a
queen trade and now black's rook is
almost trapped but not quite it moves
one square forward and
the reason we didn't like this or at
least that i didn't like this is because
now white has a central past and
protected pawn and uh also these pawns
are going to march forward at some point
soon
this white knight is firmly entrenched
in black's position it's going to be
hard to get rid of actually and it feels
like definitely these central pawns
combined with their fellows here are
going to be far more valuable than these
pawns that black has which are simply
doing nothing which if anything are just
targets
yeah yeah looking very bad for blackhead
totally um i mean i love the plan that
you suggested with pushing that f pawn
two squares forward
make it go one more square as well yeah
all the way up the board and then like
you say it's it's
what is black's plan i mean you can't
push pawns not easy not easy and and
every trade piece trade that you make
you kind of simplify the position and
that's in white's favor
you could also even start or at some
point flicking just a rook move to
eliminate black's most active piece you
could just trade off a set of rooks here
and
there's some attack against this pawn
black can plug this file plug this line
with a knight with a bishop
but this piece is just offside and now
you could continue with this plan
pushing forward and i think white is in
the driver's seat you could even
relocate this knight round
and okay yes pancoat decides to move his
rook across i guess he just wants to fix
a black's knight on this square
a slow move not as quick and as direct
to some of the plans we mentioned but
still looks pretty good for white i have
to say you guys so it's looking good for
er sepenko against magnus carlsen here
and
this plan from the champions chester
organizers to have more fighting chess
it really seems to be working i don't
think
we have seen a game today lasting less
than 30 minutes and at least all the
games that we have followed have been
fireworks all the time yeah true on
social media sometimes i receive
messages saying oh why was this player
picked or why was this picked also we've
invited some really young hungry players
to the tour and that's contributing and
that's definitely helping but i think
the system the new system is going to be
fantastic
it's everything that we needed for chess
just to show that it is a sport it is
all about the fighting and the players
have that incentive now to fight in
every single game yeah definitely i'm
just looking back at the past results as
well barely any draws and even those
draws were fighting games right to the
bit of death yeah yeah
and that's what we want isn't that
like 14 move draws not exciting for
anyone yes i understand you know the
players want to get on to the next stage
but this one this way you know with
fighting chess and with financial
incentives it gives them players that
little bit of extra motivation yeah and
uh yeah i i like it
and it's probably not going to be enough
with the draws anymore to make it to the
knockout stage because it is so many
more points for for those wins you're
gonna need to to go all in to get some
wins yeah we mentioned this type of
football scoring system with the prize
money but
i mean in football if if a team just
draws all of their games for the whole
season they'll just get relegated or
they'll barely stay up in the division
and now uh we definitely won't be able
to see players just coast to the
finishing line even if they start really
well
no chance but if they start really badly
there's always chances to be yeah that's
true as well yeah
oh yeah what a start to the season you
guys we have fighting chess from the
get-go and magnus carlsen is in trouble
in game three against andreas penco look
at those games at the bottom as well the
arrows the evaluation they're like going
crazy yeah
look at that
mamadiaro uh may be making a comeback
after two losses so far shakuri and
mamdia are one of the most entertaining
players in the world ian pognati he also
started
with a loss today but could he be about
to win against anish giri
yeah looks like there's a lot of drama
going on in round three here and the
young vincent kaimer from germany
beating level erroneous right now wow oh
look at that
yeah so much drama but uh meanwhile a
lot of drama on this board and one thing
as well that i've noticed maybe magnus
had a connection issue because he got
given some time back
earlier we thought he
maybe just hated his position he spent a
lot of time on the clock but it does
look like maybe he was just disconnected
and um here we do give the time back we
want to make sure each game is fair
so yeah we'll check back in on the clock
times we'll confirm that those are
correct a bit later but either way it
looks like magnus
i mean i'm pretty sure he doesn't like
his position but he didn't spend as long
on the clock earlier as we thought
and uh
just going back to the board we actually
see a move played by esipenko where he's
kind of almost admitted that maybe his
rook earlier move was a mistake
because he could have offered this trade
and uh the point is that if black were
to capture the rook then white would
have wasted time by just moving the rook
from the f1 square to the c1 square and
then moving it again
yeah both players losing losing moves in
this game that's something we tell uh
you know when people are learning the
game we say never lose time every move
is important every move matters but here
they're just mocking us they're laughing
okay i lost time with my rook uh earlier
magnus lost time with his knight it all
balances out in the end it's just about
whether they are going for the most
effective plans it's not necessarily
about timing yet and that's because the
center's blocked if the center doesn't
have too many pawns then every move um
the
kind of price behind every move is so
much higher when the center is slightly
blocked as it is now with the pawns
stopping each other advancing then you
can take a little bit more time there's
a bit a bit more leeway
in terms of the speed of your moves and
we do see the rook trade and now black's
knight has blocked the white rook at
least temporarily
and uh still liking white's position
ivanka loving white's position and uh i
was gonna suggest this move actually
just uh
the knights was being dominated by the
black pawn on g6 so why not move it
and uh okay so magnus just solidifying
his pawn structure
yep they're just creating those pawn
chains making sure everything protects
each other and i think now or at least
very soon is the time for white to start
pushing forward pawns even in front of
his own king now the queens are off
white's king will never really be in any
danger so i wouldn't be surprised to see
esopenko start throwing those pawns up
the board that's the site he's stronger
on after all that's where he has the
poor majority if you cut the board in
half
if you just take the four
files on the left and the four files on
the right white has a four versus two
majority on the right half
and that's where he should be playing
black meanwhile we'll try and play on
the other flank but it's maybe harder
for black to initiate those pawn pushes
because black's pieces aren't ready to
support those pawns
so
it sounds simple when you break it down
like that but i do think essence needs
to keep things simple especially because
he's going a bit low on the clock right
now
okay interesting move though he brings
his bishop forward just cutting
across some potential black plans
stopping black's knight at the top of
the board from ever leaping forward
uh that's nightmare dominated that's
quite a sneaky move do you think he has
plans of actually attacking the black
rook
and uh once he's attacked the black rook
by retreating the knight then he's
forcing a trade
of the bishop for the night yes and then
just kind of saying that that bishop is
like the linchpin of black's defense
once it's gone
my bishop is superior okay really
interesting that didn't even really
cross my mind ivanka but now you said it
it's definitely in the air so right now
this bishop has landed on this square
that's actually a very good attacking
square if the queens were on white would
be very optimistic here because the
black king would be in danger and that
this bishop does cut across uh on this
diagonal
as you mentioned i'm not really sure
what black could do to wait for example
if the black pawn pushes it's a bit
loose though
but now white could just retreat the
knight we could see a trade and maybe
the white bishop will jump in now maybe
white's pawns will match forward
still looking very very good for white
i'm slightly reluctant personally to
remove this knight yet just because it's
so strong it's so dominant and does
prevent the
opposition knight from moving but
it's definitely something an extra for
magnus carlsen to think about right now
and personally i would be thinking okay
now is the time to push push and then
try and support these pawns pushing even
further later on yeah um yeah a nice
idea though yeah
and one thing i just kind of wanted to
mention about the black counter play you
know say black really tries to play
aggressively and push his pawns he can't
do it he's not ready for it because uh
after pawn takes pawn every move has its
consequence and then the white knight
that relocated itself from g3 square has
a role to attack two pawns and this pawn
is indefensible now
this would win a pawn for white so
magnus now instead choosing a bit of a
weird move
bringing his rook forward i guess he's
hoping maybe that he can destabilize the
white bishop but he's also uh trying to
tempt estepenko into being a bit hasty
and push this pawn forward because now
at least the black rook could get into
the white position and come from behind
to activate itself
it's yeah
a very strange move to have to play but
maybe there was just nothing else
blackstruck pushing forward now and
yeah i mean there's so many tempting
moves for white here i see three or four
immediately that i want to suggest is
that a problem though with uh 50 seconds
on the clock exactly yes that's the one
thing that can get in the way of
esopenko now there's just too many good
moves he could bring his knight across
gain time against the black rook force
it back where it came from he could
start pushing one of these two pawns
just so many options right now he has to
be a little bit careful because i think
i spot the idea behind is to actually
bring his king forward to attack the
knight
okay as well to attack this
but wait one second you know essepengo
has really
laid a very surprising move because i
did not expect him to attack the rook
and allow the rook to penetrate onto the
third row yep now the rook has access
that's why white's bishop has retreated
both sides losing time here black using
the rook several times white also
spending valuable moves with his bishop
maybe now magnus can try to at some
point bring his king forward but he has
to be a bit wary of his foot getting
trapped i think actually if the king
does march forward then the white knight
will step back and suddenly the rook
might be doomed so
suddenly getting very very sharp let's
go back to the players okay magnus does
bring his king we're going to see it
david it's trapped that black rook is
trapped the white knight jumping back
actually there retreating not always
easy to see knight retreats are the most
difficult move to find in chess but
magnus's idea is that he's attacking
this white knight now he's trying to
release his rook from that cage
but the
brook is still trapped rick is still
trapped black's king needs to move now
to create some escape squares there we
go the black king stepping back where it
came from creating the escape squares
for the black rook if the white king
steps up which i'm pretty sure it will
there we go the black rook can zoom all
the way back
but who has weakened the position more
white's knight is offside now on the
edge of the board but white does have
these pawn pushes yeah to explode things
open exactly and talking about pawn
pushes i was going to say harry move him
up the board and after pawn takes pawn
look at those
pawns coming and uh yeah totally and uh
well
there was uh some
two sides advanced their pawns on the
right side and only one side benefited
and that was essie pango look at those
two nights they're just hovering in
jumping into those very weak squares f5
h5
outposts exactly yeah look at the
evaluation park i uh it's suddenly up
and plus three for white and material is
level on the board
i mean that is normally a signal if a
computer loves your position so much to
say plus three plus four and it's level
material it means you have complete
domination and look at magnus's face
right now he is cringing wincing he
hates his position
he's just been outplayed again by
esopenko esepenko is in his head he's
one of the players who he's
fears the most magnus carlsen and
rightly so judging by this game the
white knight as ivanka mentioned is
going to jump forward to f5 and
that might just be game over the white
knights are just going to be too strong
is this very close now to magnus's first
loss of the 2022 season basically he's
hovering on the brink and i i don't i'm
always going to say
magnus is not going to be able to come
back from this
strategically he's just dominated
completely and if this was over the
board classical chess i would estimate
his survival chances at five or ten
percent maximum whoa rapid maybe
slightly more but it's already at that
stage it's critical yeah his clock is uh
ticking so i guess the clock is one of
his hopes right now andres penko is uh
down on the clock but he is showing to
be very strong with little time his head
around one minute for a long time now
yeah and look at the focus on his face
chesterfenko he's barely blinked barely
looked away from the board in the last
yeah five ten minutes yeah and i have to
say he's uh
he's uh following the lavon's heronian
school of
body language
yes yes yes yes yes got this yes yes yes
yes yes he plays this yes i do that
sorry
i don't know why i mentioned this it's
true though it's keeping the adrenaline
pumped yeah
not letting the energy slip not even for
one second yeah
we had some decided games in this round
check it out mom and dad of he uh won
now his game against alexandre costeniuk
and liam liam a great win for him
against eric hansen all the other games
still going on also in draw
between abdul satoru and artemis
okay a couple of moves white's knight
has jumped forward black's king now
trying to join the defense but more
importantly the okay there has been a
trade white has won a pawn i was going
to say the black rook went passive to
defend things but white did initiate a
trade there swapping off one of his
great white knights for the black bishop
but that bishop was a key defender and
now white has actually a three versus
zero majority on the right half and
they're marching forward yeah and i was
gonna i was trying to get greedy
actually i wanted to retreat the bishop
to destabilize the knight
and uh
that would have been equally good i
think yeah everything is winning now for
esopenko he's a porn up and he has these
three pawns ready to push forward and
they will cost black at least a night
maybe even more and uh magnus just
trying to hold up the advance of those
pawns the white bishop now
it's a bit stuck if it moves then the
black rook will come down and take a
pawn but white's king can join the
action
white rook at some point we'll start
swinging across
this one actually you can even tell on
magnus's body language leaning back he
knows he's uh in huge trouble he knows
he's barely got any chance to survive
but
he's just hoping and praying for a
blunder hoping for spencer to get
nervous definitely i mean there is a
hidden threat in the position the knight
the black knight is actually threatening
to move itself to the e6 square
attacking the bishop and the pawn on d4
but he's not given time nope sepenko now
jumping forward with his own knight
attacking the black rook if the black
rook moves itself if it keeps itself on
the g-file it has to as it does then the
white rook might start swinging across
at some point um the black brook is
almost trapped actually um
there we go the white bishop just moves
the black rook forced to run away from
the attack and now i think jessepanko
can just trap that black rook
look at this the black rook entrenched
between white pieces and it's going to
be game over yep the black rook was
i mean simply nowhere to go it gives
itself up for the white knight and we've
seen a result a fist pump from esopenko
he's won he's beating the world champion
what a result from the 19 year old
making his debut in the meltdown
champions chess are winning game three
against magnus carlson the world
champion